non
et bonjour bienvenue pour cette émission
diagonale tv spéciale chorus 2007 avec
et bien nicolas giffard pour nicolas
giffard qui étaient présents d'autres
dernière émission bonjour nicolas
bonjour stéphane on va rappeler
peut-être un peu plus rapidement que sur
l'émission pression que vous invite
aussi à découvrir que tu es maître
international les premiers en france 2e
2e après elle doit hic donc champion de
france 78 et 81 2 donc pas rien quand
même deux titres de champion de france
il n'y a pas beaucoup qui présente
laurent frayssinet il peut pas dire
pareil là deux fois été vice champion je
suis je suis loin du record de buck roux
qui a 5 2 cinq d'affilée c'est ça ça il
va pas leur corps et en mai faire cinq
titres de champion de france vu le
niveau actuel
oui c'est vraiment un salaire et donc
aussi écrivain et auteur de beaucoup de
votre ouvrage d'échecs dont le guide de
le guide des échecs traité complet sous
titre est traité complet et c'est
vraiment complet il ya tout à l'histoire
du jeu
l'initiation il ya l'histoire y compris
à partir de ça de sa de sa création en
inde au cinquième siècle l'histoire via
les arabes et cetera toutes les
anecdotes le turc de napoléon l'alleud
qui est le tueur qui a fait toutes les
cours d'europe notamment napoléon écrasé
à écraser napoléon qui joue et c'est une
espèce d'automates
c'est une supercherie avait à
l'intérieur en fait et il ya toute cette
histoire autour du jeu d'échecs toute
l'évolution l'histoire des champions du
monde et toutes les parties décisives
des championnats du monde donc les
analyses et ses atouts au départ il faut
dire c'est un livre d'initiation
d'ailleurs une partie de son succès il
est dû à ça des débutants qui ne
connaissaient pas le
eh bien on s'en allait vers le jeu
d'échecs par ce livre
oui exactement et beaucoup de gens l'ont
dans leur bibliothèque et donc si vous
l'avez pas si vous faites partie des
quelques français qui l'ont pas encore
puisque plus de 40000 e bibliothèque en
france on se livre là ce qui est un
succès considérable on ne fait pas ça
les voiries je disais que chaque
bibliothèque on achète un exemple est un
média pas 40 minutes et qu'en france
non mais des bibliothèques individuel je
parle ah oui je parle pas ici d'un oui
mais il ya celle là bien sûr mais je
parlais des biotech aussi individuelle
bon ben il a sa place dans une belle
bibliothèque ce livre là il ya aussi le
dernier livre écrit en collaboration
avec jacques et le pilier qui s'appelle
sans exercice
oui avec ce qu'est le bieler on a fait
une série de trois livres d'exercices
chacun comporte cet exercice le premier
était le plus évidemment aborda par les
débutants
ensuite un deuxième et dernier s'appelle
sans exercice pour préparer vos tournois
c'est à dire qu'il s'adresse à des gens
qui ont déjà un glissement et l'eau y
sont intégrés dans la compétition voilà
on va le montrer quand même ce dernier
livre de nicholas giffard évidemment il
y en a plusieurs
plusieurs en préparation et un problème
de apparemment non mais pas de problème
donc je suis la régie qui faisait un
petit signe alors voilà donc le nicolas
giffard donc peu tout ça est trouvable
sur internet en vous avez téléchargé sur
internet donc vous avez internet et vous
pouvez aller sur les librairies online
jouer à la balle télécharger les livres
c'est normal ça on peut pas les stations
peux pas je crois que c'est pas compris
c'est pas pratique de toute façon des
emplois et heskey mais n'entend qu'eux
et bientôt peut-être y aura les livres
numériques ça sera peut-être m
puis crois pas trop c'est froid le
plastique
on verra
sur une tête il fonde et des faux
papiers qui sont courants la texture
comme le sucre une médaille on a bien
réussi à faire du faux sucre on peut
tromper les sens oui mais le livre
papier est tellement bien adapté à
l'homme que je pense que ça dure tours
toujours faut jamais dire toujours crois
que non si la lecture c'est qu'on est
dans mes lectures oui mais peut-être le
format sur lequel on lit je pense que
par exemple beaucoup de gens lisent
avant de s'endormir et je vois
difficilement autre chose que du papier
et si si on en arrive à faire un pape
qui est souple mais c'est pas grave je
crois pas un papier se fait mal aux yeux
électroniques
non mais où on verrait pas sa forêt je
sais pas bayadh et il ya des encres
aussi qu' apparemment il fait moins on
va pas parler peut-être ça aujourd'hui
mais mais c'est possible qu'en tout cas
le traité guider traité d échec soit
demain sur les ebooks là qui sont créés
etc
donc on est quand même sur internet on
est quand même aussi à la pointe des
technologies pour un nicolas jean tenter
plus un adepte du du livre du bon livre
papier même écrit à la main comme témoin
son père moyens veut dire aussi que ce
guide des échecs dont on parle et il a
une texture spéciale il est très souple
c'est du papier bible et puis il est
fait de telle manière que quand on ouvre
le livre est bien il reste ouvert à la
bonne page
il ne se referme pas tous se referme pas
exactement une très bonne qualité fillon
comme une bible sur roachs et s'est fait
bien le dire s'est il est aussi aussi
gros qu'une bible mais négligé rend à
mes bible dans la mesure où la
couverture n'est pas rigide justement
les bibles bon il le contenu à
valenciennes en tout cas moins avec des
des couvertures très dur
oui et puis le contenu un peu moins
ésotérique oui c'est vrai alors on va
maintenant parler et bien de l'actualité
brûlante de ce
de ce mois de janvier 2007 c'est à dire
le grand tournoi chorus 2007 avec une
bombe dans ce début de tournoi qui
s'appelle radjabov une espèce de bon qui
écrase tout sur son passage
après cinq parties ses quatre victoires
donc des victoires face à shirov des
victoires face à et bien de moi
vélib en délit et six vit à côté yacco
voilà c'est ça et ir un avare et il a
fait une seule nul face à kaia keane il
était gagnant il avait alors qu'il était
gagnant
donc il y aura qu entre tours et fou il
aurait dû gagner il aurait très bien pu
aussi avoir cinq sur cinq donc une
espèce de météores radjabov pas facile à
suivre est d'ailleurs pas de hasard le
seul qui arrive à peu près tenir le coup
c'est un autre météores habitué des
scores faibles fleuve sai topaloff est
pour l'instant un an des crânes xo un
tout petit peu relâché mais bon on a
encore qu'au début du tournoi il faut
quand même patienter un peu et on va
avoir une très belle partie de radjabov
qui est là surtout quelque chose qu'on
voit assez rarement maintenant c'est un
gambit en dehors du gambit marshall qui
est super analysé jusqu'au 25 août 30e
coup il ya quelquefois des gambie 1
inventé sur l'échiquier et je pense
qu'hier c'est une pure invention de
rajab box qui s'est produit parce que la
variante qu'a choisi navarra n'était pas
prévu au programme
c'est une variante assez rare et contre
ça et bien il a il a innové je pense il
a fait
un gambit absolument à l'inspiration à
l'espagne est révélatrice de la forme
directement mais on va voir que aussi
les échecs c'est un sport où la forme
compte avec cette partie navarra
radjabov donc on avait déjà les analyser
une partie radjabov a été noire ça n'est
encore une avec les noirs donc il est
dangereux cet homme-là des deux côtés
d'ailleurs on va analyser cette partie
du côté noir de façon à se mettre du
côté du plus fort en ce qui est toujours
plus agréable et même plus difficile
quand on a déjà regardé la partie de
l'autre côté
ah ouais mais ça c'est c'est justement
là tout l'intérêt des gones atv qui ne
fait pas reposer ni ses téléspectateurs
ninis et lycées invités alors on va
démarrer avec cette partie navarra
radjabov par le coût des deux des quatre
dons classiques et n'avoir à face à
ashraf avait joué comme face à vannes
délit une install yale et il dévie pas
puisqu'ils jouent 4e 6 et après 15,3 il
rentre dans un schéma est indien à
l'exercice et sur ses quatre filles et
c'est sans surprise et ses lacets
navarra qui continue par câble et c3 et
après petit rock et bien avoir a choisi
de ne pas jouer l'estonienne qui aurait
dû apparaître après le coup le 4 mai de
jouer peut-être enfin on est quand même
dans un schéma italienne toujours
sélestadienne mais il joue un coup un
peu moins peut-être percutant qui est le
coup mais j'essaie il faut dire que
navarra et des choses et par le fait que
radjabov à gagner les deux parties
précédentes avec les indiennes dans le
tournoi il a battu à la fille le
vendredi et shirov oui il a peur il n'a
pas voulu affronter
il donne l'impression d'une vraie
machine de l'estagnol oui il a analysé
ça tellement profondément
alors ils jouent la variante smith love
ou g5 que personnellement j'ai pratiqué
aussi beaucoup et que m'avait apprises
aldo haïk et qui est censé un peu calmé
jeu c'est à dire ah bon on est moins
ambitieux parce qu'en général on fait
suivre le cours ou g5 par eu deux ou
trois le pion aux roses une seule case
voilà pourquoi pour pas être embêté
croire voilà et surtout pour fermer la
diagonale du fou g7 disons qu'on
neutralise un peu
la pièce dans et noir pour laquelle les
noirs le plus d'ambition c'est le foot
g7 alors avec le coup de trois on le met
un peu saoul et et noir donc la
classique peut-être dans cette situation
shirov fin radjabov pardon réagi comme
il faut avec le pouce et 5 tout de suite
il ya plusieurs variantes oui mais c'est
5 c'est une possibilité de casser le
centre est normalement un joueur comme
moi ou comme aldo haïkus comme ceux qui
jouent beaucoup cette variante fouge et
5 contres c'est ça qui préfère ne pas
pousser leurs pions des rentrées dans
une défense d'ennemis mais plutôt joué 2
3 ça serait une manière calme de
continuer en navarre
voilà mais où les noirs égalise plus
facilement aussi il faut dire alors
navarra il accepte lui aussi le défi ce
qui nous a valu une belle partie des
cinq qui décide donc il choisi de
pousser le coeur mais du coup donne de
l'air au fusil et 7 qui maintenant une
belle diagonale bien ouverte et
d'ailleurs et c'est là que doivent elles
vantent alors je pense que ici au
radjabov et ne connaissais pas
particulièrement cette position enfin
j'imagine radjabov est très fort déjà
joué beaucoup murray son jeune âge mais
j'ai l'impression que ce qu'il a joué
mais absolument pas répertorié j'ai pas
vérifié sur les banques de données mais
on joue rarement le gambit qu'il a joué
quand les blancs peuvent prendre avec
une pièce will have on le fait quand les
blancs peuvent prendre avec le voilà ce
qu il va faire une sorte de granby benko
différé c'est un peu tard oui et puis
d'une manière qui n'ouvre pas vraiment
le jeu pour la torah 8 comme d'un
candidat normal et donc qui est a priori
un peu suspect et on va voir
c'est le coût des cinq voies la donne le
pion après si les blancs avaient pris
avec le pion sekkat on serait retombé
dans des situations habituellement lobby
de la volga on joue à six
or jouer à 6 les colonne s'ouvre sur les
mains et sur qui on prend on prend du
fou on a donné un pion mais on va
échanger contre le fouet fin on voit que
les noirs ont un jeu de pièces à ses
actifs après ça voilà on mean to ra8 une
tour ambiguïté on attaque les pions à
2002 en revanche après est-ce que
rahnavard a joué cavalier prendre qui
ont terminé 1er juin
un compensation est moins net parce que
là colonna est fermé pour les noir et
noir n'ont que la colonne des faux pas
jouer à 6 pour changer la pression des
noirs se mêlent dame elle est moindre
et est ce que ça vaut un pion mais a
priori on peut avoir l'impression que
n'ont en tout cas pas les vosges ou sans
doute le bon coup dans cette situation
ces cavaliers aux quatre vents y avait
un joueur qui jouait comme ça avec les
noirs j'ai eu plusieurs parties à une
certaine époque c'était velimir ochowicz
joueur serbe celui qui avait inventé la
fameuse attaque avec les noirs souvent
ils jouaient sorte de gambie mais bon
c'est de valeur douteuse parce que on
vient de le dire
la colonne a n'est pas ouvert donc très
intéressant le cancale 4 parce que ça
contrôler les cases noires des 2 6 3
donc ça peut aider d'un certain qu'à un
échec de la dame à 5
et en plus ça libère la force du fou g7
sur le pion b2 et en même temps ça ça a
plus ou moins ça attaque le fou donc ça
fait beaucoup
alors il a joué le coup logique navarra
fou c'est un donc foussier revient à la
maison
il a encaissé un pion et maintenant ils
jouent pour garder le matériel en disant
que le noir n'ont pas beaucoup de jeux
sur les dames et non que la colonne b
est difficile à exploiter parce qu'il y
avait les v8 qui étaient encore à deux
coups de pouvoir attractif
c'est apparemment un gambit qui n'est
pas valable
il n'y a pas tous les critères du palais
bon critère du gambie la gambie alors à
6 aux bons moments ont sans doute aussi
pour rhodia bof moi ça m'a surpris ce qu
à six parce que quoi 6 peut-être dans la
case obs noir oui ça ramène le cavalier
blanc en défense
j'ai pas vu en tout cas on peut pas
revenir en c3 a tout de suite puisqu'il
ya fouet le canal de venir en a trois
peut-être qu'il a peur aura d'abord que
les blancs se développe par daems et 2
tout de suite et après on peut revenir
en c3 c'est possible alors car il ya
trois donc forcé et maintenant damas
cinquième place et leur donc on fait un
échec
ici le cavalier ici en pêche pour les
blancs de mettre la dame où le fou sa
force la réplique des blancs venir et le
pion b2 reste attaqué donc il faut jouer
cavalier d2 on appelle trop le choix en
fait un cahier des deux mais qui peut
être suffisant ces problèmes ce genre de
coup et après aussi se maintenant
maintenant les noirs veulent essayer
d'ouvrir les les colonnes alors ce qu'on
a vu sur cette analyse qui était en
direct sur sur i say say yes fm avec
donc la radio shems fm qui commentent en
direct c'est ce chorus 2007 avec le
maître international ti mais j'avais
avait noté que le problème du coût aussi
ceux ci c'est quand on prend des cinq
après la prise on libère une case pour
le terrier à 3 qu'elle a cassé quatre
avec un gain de temps sur la dame mais
qui est quand même très belles cases
pour le cavalier puisque cette case ne
peut pas être attaquée par un pion donc
c'est le contrecoup de soukous 6 qui de
l'autre côté aussi peut ouvrir la
colonne eu avec la tour contre le roi
blanc oui puis je crois qu'il veut aussi
mettre en jeu de manière active le fou
ces huit ans bessette comme des 5
normalement le pion central des blancs
ne va pas pouvoir être soutenus
suffisamment apparemment vous noir
aurait une diagonale pour lui sous sa
domination
donc c'est pourquoi les blancs jouent g3
pour jouer un peu contre cette idée fut
bessette pour mettre un frein aux anges
et 2 et maintenant après eux prend des 5
fu g2 par nabarra donc maintenant là les
blancs bombés dix bombes et déjà tu peux
pas prendre ces quatre évidemment
puisque le cavalier est en prise alors
là il ya déjà des combines possible il
faut faire attention sur un coup comme
comme fou bessette par exemple on peut
montrer c'est pas clair clair c'est pas
facile pour l'épauler blanc parce qu'on
pourrait prendre pour les noirs pardon
on pourrait prendre des 5 et surtout
prend des scènes tout simplement faire
le petit rock et maintenant le cavalier
ou 4 est attaqué et on notera aussi que
la torah 8t derrière le foot chez deux
ça obligerait les noirs à tous et f5 du
magic et voilà et f5 marche pas ah bon
et non parce qu'il y aurait tout
simplement cavale et prend le cas de
nicolas attaquant le fou des 5es sur
pions sur fou prend 2,4 et bien tout
simplement en échange les fous et après
pions prend la pointe dan des cinq
échecs attaque laurent et la tour à 8
alors hamas une tour au passage
donc attention quand même pour radjabov
après coup j'ai deux ça devient très
délicat du fait que l'a45 qu'une caste
très faible maintenant et qui derrière
mais en porte-à-faux un peu la tour la
torah 8 donc si pourquoi radjabov tout
calculé choisi de jouer le coup cavale
et prendre des deux et là on est à un
carrefour qui est quand même important
là il y avait une possibilité pour les
blancs de prendre avec la dame
oui moi n'a pas fait il aurait fait
quand j'ai perdu la partie
voilà ce qu'on n'a pas fait rajab
bizarrement parce que en cas d' échange
de dames est tout simplement prendre du
roi on continue à garder donc un oeil
sur le plan b de attaqué par le fou g7
on prendrait durant et après le pont des
scènes de toute façon on ne peut pas
bouger puisque le fou j'ai deux clous
sur la torah 8 et on aurait pu
consolider le peut-être le pion de
l'option de plus dans cette dans cette
configuration et d'avoir n'a pas choisi
de jouer ce coup qui avait l'air
pourtant très sonné il n'a pas voulu
rester avec son roi en d2 bloquant le
fou c'est un je pensais pas harmonieux
salué un peu plus visuellement c'est
ouais c'est pas attirant du tout c'est
pas tyran visuellement mais peut-être
que c'était même la manière de garder le
pion de plus de façon peut être un peu
plus un peu plus frappante à londres
haut lieu de dames prendre des deux est
bien fou prend des deux a été jouée par
navarra le projet vous prendrez de tout
de suite c'est que ça va perdre encore
une tant sur le plan b 2 qui est attaqué
en fait il est très ambitieux parce
qu'on va voir qui sacrifie la qualité
maintenant avec les blancs donc dam des
huit dalles des vite pour radjabov et
après pions prendre des cinq les noirs
pouvaient gagner la qualité par fou
prend b2 mais ça aurait été trop risqué
ça vous prend b2 voilà exactement alors
sur fou prend b2 est immense qu'on avait
peut-être analyser avec etienne match
c'est tout simplement pouvait jouer l'
attaque avec cavale et c4 effectivement
pour gagner un temps ici sur le fou
mettre le cavalier sur une très belle
case pour attaquer une fois déjà à la
caisse des six et quand une case
importante
et puis après on est fou prend tour et
tout cela en prend il y aurait déjà la
menace ou m6 qui reviennent la qualité
déjà la menace effectivement fois ci ce
qu'ils attaquent la tour et qui menacent
mat
angers7 voilà donc et aussi on peut
jouer des variantes comme
comme aussi comme fou c3 avec des idées
fusent et cette fois je suit enfin y'a
plein de rock noir trou et trouver
exactement dans très difficile d'autant
plus que quand on commet n'a pas encore
ok on peut on peut marier cette attaque
avec des attaques comme h 4 h 5
ça devient ça peut devenir très
dangereux donc c'était l'idée d'un
navarra donc d'amd 8 go prend des 5 il a
pas peur de vous prendre en b2 et
radiologues tombe pas dans le piège du
tout et joue un plan très intelligent
très fin et radiographies joue à 5
oui parce qu'il veut contester le
cavalier blanc qui va se diriger sur la
case c4 il veut pouvoir
il veut pouvoir pousser je veux pouvoir
pousser jusqu'à 4 il ya aussi ça oui en
cas en cas de cavaliers qu'amélie a
décidé de faire rejouer le fou ses huit
ans à 6 il veut jouer le fou c'est
vitara suisse et en mettant le pion à 4
il va se retrouver dans une
configuration quasi classique de gambie
benko finalement puisque le plu en
quatre est bien placé pour faire
pression sur les pions à 2 b 2 il n'a
pas peur de le perdre parce que la
pression sera terrible sur les pions et
il va miser la colonne b pour attaquer
qui ont b2 et c'est pourquoi en avoir a
tout de suite choisi de jouer fous ces
trois pour échanger le fou g7 dont
classique un opposition de fou il veut
échanger absolument se fout set mais il
était clair que le fond blanc des deux
était beaucoup plus passif que son nom
gsm il va changer la grosse pièce
adverse et la radio fed entame son
développement tranquillement avec des
six maintenant que les fous de khadra
vont s'échanger le pion des six témoins
sera moins faible et il va jouer une
sorte de benoni un peu classique petit
rock de benoni d'un bingo pardon et la
maintenance fois ci ça y est voilà le
fouille sur sa case naturel il tape sur
le pion est de 1 conduction avec la tour
8 par exemple commence à faire un peu
pression sur le sur le pion aux deux
dames d2 pour navarre attaque le pion à
cinq attaques fou et dames pour le pion
à 5 et la foux prend ces trois tout
simplement pour à jabot choisi
d'éliminer le fou mais en même temps il
élimine la faiblesse blanche sur la
colonne
maintenant il élimine effectivement
hélas les blancs un pion de plus
finalement assez à senna et les blancs
vont pouvoir bloquer le fou à 6 par ces
quatre derrière c'est parce que ça
semble plutôt favorable au plan ça
semble favorable au blanc effectivement
qui on prend ces trois là peut-être on
peut considérer effectivement que ce
niveau là on revient aux femmes et n'a
pas vraiment pour l'instant justifier le
pion demain le pion de moins et le gant
beats et même la barre à qui s'en sort
plutôt bien qu'elle avait 17 dont qui
ternit son développement radjabov dont
il continue à jouer la partie normale
évidemment tourab et un f5 de maintenant
de radjabov donc f5 avec l'idée sans
doute de d'empêcher d'empêcher le 4 de
toute façon tôt ou tard qu'il est aussi
dans l'idée des blancs de façon à
peut-être affaiblir le pion des cinq
aussi oui il veut effectivement
peut-être pouvoir jouer cavalier f6
derrière le pur f5 voilà et tour 8es
pour voir jouer des carriers leucate
aussi des possibilités comme ça
peut-être qu'elle a également il ya une
impossibilité pour attaquer derrière
cette poussée f54 c'est un classique
contre un rock bien sûr aussi une
possibilité si de 2 pour casser le un
petit peu la chaîne de pions défensive
du rock leblanc alors il faut remarquer
sur un plan stratégique général que les
noirs sont en manque d espace dans une
configuration puisque le pion blanc un
des cinq de plus l'espace encan blanc
les blancs plus d espace de manoeuvre
derrière leur ligne
noir mais s'est atténuée par le fait
qu'ils et plusieurs échanges de deux
pièces mineurs dans chaque concurrent
disparu et on sait bien que le camp qui
a le moins d'espacé a intérêt à échanger
les pièces puisque ces pièces sont moins
gênés par le manque d espace donc
stratégiquement au moins il ya sept
ce facteur favorable à radjabov c'est
que dans une structure comme ça avec
avantage des espaces pour les blancs et
bien il ya eu déjà des échanges de
pièces car les baies 5 et jouer
maintenant par navarra donc normal il
met le cap à l'est sur une case active
qui attaque tout de suite le pion des
six et en même temps ils bougent un peu
l'avenir du x 6 et la map répond par un
coup logique aussi cavalier e cn qui
veut à la fois profiter maintenant du de
la paix est une belle kazan le 5 même si
ce qu'elle peut être chassés mais ça
affaiblit reppion modeuses de toute
façon est aussi veut profiter peut-être
de cette case c4 qui est faible
maintenant puisque le but maintenant que
lecavalier ne contrôle plus sur a3 et
bien c'est qu'alors je crois qu'il ya un
phénomène maintenant aussi dans cette
partie radjabov était en retard à la
pendule et à partir de ce moment là va
se montrer trop optimiste je pense qu'à
cause de sa cause du fait que radjabov
avait peu de temps il a imaginé que ça
allait être facile que ça allait être
facile voilà que la violence ne
trouverait pas les meilleurs coups et là
il a été très bon à partir de maintenant
radjabov se montre au niveau des parties
qu'il a jouées contre shiro fait
contrevent novelli c'est à dire qui va
trouver une attaque à partir de ne pas
rendre à grand chose et il va construire
une attaque ultra rapide là pour navarra
il est peut-être temps là de consolider
leur son cavalier certes voilà pour
consolider son cavalier b5 et boucher
l'avenir du x 6 déjà aux coups
précédents elle pouvait jouer ses quatre
saisons précédentes où ses 4o coups
précédents maintenant c'est trop tard et
le cavalier 5 et ils jouent aux quatre
coups un peu plus
un peu plus tendue puisque puisqu'ils
prennent de 4,6 au cavalier permanente
de biens peut clouer parce que le x 6
tape sur la tour eiffel à la tour f 1
donc ça affaiblit un peu cette diagonale
là tout de suite
bon et on va voir la suite des sonorités
c'est peut-être dé débloquer la colle la
diagonale h3c 8 pour que le fou j'ai
deux puis s'infiltrer en eux aussi dans
certaines il peut jouer sur h3 pour
venir aussi dans certaines actuellement
évidemment c'est pas possible il ya la
case f3 à surveiller mais hélas il veut
profiter aussi du fait que le roi noir
après les échanges de coups de fil des
tours est un peu faible le roi noir il
est dans les courants d'air donc s'il
ouvre le jeu autour de roanne loire
ça peut être bon pour les blancs il a
peut-être raté nabarra le coup simple
cavale et c4 parce qu'en fait la dame ne
peut plus venir n'y a eu ni en d3 par
exemple sur dam des trois tout
simplement le coup cavaler à trois
fourchettes pour cavaliers et le fou
attaque la dame s'était fait s'ils
avaient bougé d'ailleurs alors sur ces 2
et bien sûr les casses sur la casse ces
deux c'est pareil il va prendre une
fourchette sur la case savez puisque
alors une amende car les c4 sur la casse
et de il va prendre une fourchette aussi
puisqu'on fait fou pour travailler et
après tout reprend et bien tout
simplement car il ya 3 et donc il n'a
pas de gaz en fait navarra carrière
complète n'y a pas de gaza 21 jan adam
d1 alors d'âme des uns oui messieurs
dames d1 où il ya des matches 6 s'il
peut aller à la table il peut voilà il
aurait pu venir peut-être en damage 6 ou
d'amd 1
mais attention la fourchette ou fourche
est aussi possible par exemple imaginons
alors sur dame
damages si c'est tout à fait possible
tout à fait la maj 6 mais là on voit
bien que par exemple sur pions prend 2,4
il ya des possibilités de fourchette ici
en d2 plus tard qu'ils peuvent être
embêtante
même s'il est bon la dame contrôle
encore à la casse des 2 mai ah oui puis
3-4 menacerait aussi d'un sacré mais par
exemple sur fou prend 1,4 nicolas il
peut y avoir un coup comme d'hab 1,8
attaque à la fois le fou protège la
classe du 6 et attaquent aussi le
cavalier b5
c'est ça devient compliqué quoi ça
devient alors que la position était
calme après camaïeu cinq ici et que
navarra ici pouvait jouer une
consolidation par à 4 tout simplement il
jouer peut-être quatre un peu trop tôt
mais non d'un autre côté ce qui va
obtenir 100 prometteur après les coups
qui ont été joués alors on va voir ce
qu'on va voir que le roi noir va se
retrouver complètement nuit cavale et
ses quatre dames c'est un pur donc
d'abord à une des rares cases
disponibles pour la dame ils
s'assemblent tout semble ok pour les
blancs et là il joue il vous fait notre
amie radjabov puisqu'ils jouent le coup
à 4 l'idée de l'a46 simplement
d'empêcher à 4 pour les noirs et en même
temps donc ça ça déstabilise un peu le
cas les vaisselles puisque maintenant il
peut être attaqué par dame 8 part
éventuellement damas cinq par damas par
20 minutes parce qu'il ya eu 17 plus tôt
voilà d'amd cette attaque et le cavalier
et ce cavalier a pas de gaz
il a pas de calais donc c'est embêtant
il est peut-être pas vu tout ça n'avoir
donc comprend f5 et métronome 17
et voilà où va le cavalier il est pris
au piège et il est obligé de sacrifier
mais comme il a déjà un pion du gambit
un deuxième pion en prenant à f/5 il va
en avoir un troisième en prenant g6 donc
il a déjà trois pions déjà trois pions
noirs
est pas le plus tranquille le plus
tranquille pour un moment bien sûr mais
l'autre côté on a l'impression en tout
cas comme ça en réfléchissant rapidement
rapidement que le roi noir et très mal
qui a une grosse compensation parce
qu'il ya la colonne d'eau pour les tours
blanches qui peuvent s'intégrer c'est
qui va de regarder compensation avait de
bonnes chances pour les ans ça sent
quand même c'est moins clair du coup ça
redonne des chances au noir alors que le
nom était semblait verrouillé semblait
avoir laissé le choix d'avoir fait aux
cadres d'avoir ouvert le jeu ouais c'est
peut-être un lent faut bien sûr mais
assez prometteur au premier coup d'oeil
on peut un peu optimiste alors pions
pranger 6 il a maintenant fou prend des
cinq gagne une pièce tout simplement
maintenant d'alger 5 alors ça c'est
malin puisque sur pied un projet si son
fruit de simplement d'un projet ici si
on a là nul puisque la chaire puisque si
la dame bien protégé le fourbe et 5
serait emprise de la tour moi
j'attendais plus tôt d'un match 6 ça me
semblait plus virulent que dame et g5
mais en fait sur damage 6
j'avoue j'ai fait tourner le moteur
d'analysé et qui a le cou cavaliers à 3
way et kookaï à trois qu'il ya qui est
très fort parce que ces attaques de tous
ça attaque de la fabrique encore un
sacrifice des blancs et là c'est trop
cher ça attaque de la tour par le
cavalier et par le fou non et puis le
coup damas six paires mais ce qu'il faut
voir aussi le couffo h3 derrière ford
alors on peut le montrer on peut le
montrer
on met 5 imaginons damage 6 voilà
cavaliers à trois ou quatre il ya trois
attaques latour b1 et attaque aussi le
plateau f1 fourrage trois jeux 3ds mais
c'est pas grave attaque la dame est ce
qu'on voudra mais j'essaie d'amener cet
échec est roi a chuté bien passé il n'y
a pas vraiment d attaque pour les blancs
après 3h 8 ya plus rien il ya surtout
d'autour attaquer donc il y aura à la
fin une tour de moins chez nous et c'est
insuffisant
ça fait beaucoup autour de montmirail a
que trois pions trois pions ça fait pas
du tout oui puis la taxe semble quand
même un peu limite il va manquer une
pièce d'attaquants cavaliers en plus ici
ça serait pas mal mais il n'ya pas donc
d'alger 5 et là maintenant kallio cinq
radios provient tout simplement en
défense ils bouchent la colonne en même
temps aussi cette fameuse colonne oui
alors s'il avait joué cavalier à trois
c'est ça qu'il faut voilà alors ça
aurait été moins précis cavalia
troisième qualité c'est moins précis
parce qu'il ya toujours un peu importe
laquelle celle-ci par exemple suivi de
tours 7
on menace menace toerseth et surtour à
ie8 ça laisse aux blancs les le temps
d'éviter la perte de la qualité
voilà il peut jouer peut-être des tours
aussi statut ont tous joué des tours aux
six actuellement chance d' attaque on
peut oser changer les tours tout
simplement alors dame g5 donc cavalier
5,2 radjabov tout simplement nom qui
revient en défense aussi ils menacent
eux peut-être de reprendre une plongée 6
euros mais ils ramènent une pièce une
pièce en défense et en même temps et
quand même un petit oeil sur la tour
eiffel et la viande rouge cet échec
doubles échecs dames
alors on sait que paradoxalement et qui
va et le mieux protégé par un pion
adverse
white leroy ensuite parce qu'on peut pas
le prendre voilà 3 juin il est mieux
protégé par un pion blanc que par un
pion concert de ce pion comme rempart en
fait sauf si évidemment les blancs peut
infiltrer la dame angers
une bonne défense sur la huitième pour
l'instant touré feu un logique et la
jolie kudo radjabov aussi défense food
et 3 très malin puisque le fois ci ce
qui a fini son travail sur la grande
diagonale vient attaquer un petit peu la
tournée droite et va pouvoir revenir
par exemple en prenant un petit orage
tête on pourrait contrôler des cases pré
du roi et ça fait du bien d'avoir un
défenseur ça évite aussi des fous et 4
éventuelles et la position noir et
gagnante ici j'ai fait tourner le moteur
il n'y a pas de solution le cavalier
noir est extrêmement fort et puis les
tournois toutes les pièces noires sont
en jeu en fait et l'attaquent blanche
inexistante lé droit et devoir s'imposer
dans donc la navarre à un peu obligé de
sacrifier donc on peut dire que là il
avait quand même gagné un peu la
bataille de l'ouverture et puis là il a
été trop optimiste avait secoué 4 oui
c'est ça alors on va on va suivre
maintenant tombé 6 et il a été négligent
désinvolte surtout avec son cavalier b5
qui est en danger
oui il n'a pas soulevé la paella voilà
c'est le coup à 4 qui l'a qui l'a
complètement sous-estimé mésestimé par
tours b 6 donc peut-être le meilleur
coût pour les blancs fait pression sur
le pion des six acthib la tour et
maintenant
radjabu ramène la dernière pièce qui
jouait pas vers le centre et on peut
dire qu'il a optimisé son positionnement
il a une pièce de plus dans l'évident
pour la pièce il ya 1 2 3 on peut pas
considérer que le curage 7 millions de
plus parce qu'il peut être pris un peu
n'importe quand est-ce que trois points
suffisent pour la pièce souvent c'est un
peu insuffisant sauf s'ils sont bien
avancés oui il faut dire que les caps
pièces noires sont au maximum de leur
activité alors ont déjà des menaces il
ya une menace ya menace cavaliers f3
échec au roi brand et tourmenté après la
tour ou un est en échec
suivi de suivi d'un acte est une erreur
dans des positions aiguë celui qui
aligne sept
c'est un gros avantage donc des simples
fait c'est déterminant dans le jugement
de la position le fait que ce soit les
noirs qui attaquent les premiers ya
d'abord tu choisis pas le meilleur coup
là il est un coup c'était quoi un chien
ou f4
c'était assez difficile à difficile à
dire difficile à dire mais c'est le
problème pour les blancs c'est qu'il ait
les pieds sont déjà au maximum il
fallait peut-être joué un coup comme h3
tout simplement coup d'attendre
maintenant on peut voir papa est un peu
pas y'a pas c'est vrai c'est pas
possible non enlever la tour de la
colonie ont enlevé à taureaux colonna
mais dans ce cas là c'est un lord à m le
droit c'est un peu c'est ce qu'il a fait
navarra il a joué un des rares coups
possibles tour 3 pour éviter cette
manoeuvre est là mais ils oublient une
combinaison à base de câbles et c4
fourchette double tour et ça pose un
gros souci il faut qu' il faut que les
noirs prennent la tour e 8 mai il
accable la tour
la tourbe et 6 va continuer à être
attaqué avec une menace de tours eu un
échec ça fait beaucoup
parce que la tourbe et 6 peut pas
revenir ça ma première rangée les cases
bien et contrôler contrôlée par le fou
voilà et l'avare à la maintenant mais il
est perdu il est il est un peu perdu un
peu perdu les repères la qualité effet
tout reprendre des 3 voilà qu'il allait
derrière rangs de la partie donc la
c-max seimat force et donc on va voir
belle combinaison match donc on peut
dire ici
nicolas faites vous la main sans
exercice non là c'est ce serait dans le
premier tome
sa méthode pour les évidents c'est trop
facile c'est quand même essayé de sonner
chez courroye il ya un tout petit peu de
travail
alors c'est au noir de jouer ça coule
vraiment de source
c'est matt horth un peu sur un peu long
mais finalement si un peu inévitable
non c'est pas long en faveur des gens
qu'il faut une défense désespérée
voilà c'est ça alors c'est assez facile
finalement à dungu tour échec voilà
fouet fin forcé y'a pas d'autres coûts
et maintenant tout simplement damas
trois oncles ou cercueil la menace
d'emprunt f1 est complètement imparable
les blancs ne peuvent plus que faire des
échecs on se lasse de consolation
d'ailleurs week encore quant à les
joueurs jouent ce genre de coup c'est un
peu par des pignes oui il aurait pu
abandonner sans doute il avait voulu
pour les spectateurs faire un peu
d'émotion dans simplement il est dépité
je crois qu'il est complètement dépité
il sait qu'il a ici qu'il a raté la
partie ouais non et puis il espère
peut-être un miracle de manière
apparemment donné il a que le coup qu'il
a joué
qui est possible cela il le fait mais
c'est un idée matin c'est un coup
d'ordinateur oui les autres coûts
d'ordinateurs pour retarder le match
serait offert un échec face au silence
et matt donc dame g8 échec mois la tour
penchée 8 h 30 g 8 dan roy prend est
maintenant un petit échec b8 et après
roger 7,6 abandon le prochain coup des
blancs qui peut jouer ses tours b 7 3 et
6 et a maintenant 3 1 face à s'expose
encore un an pas à part ses droits ou g6
projet si c'est là le seul coup après
ces tours g7 de chèques donné la tour et
à bien des rois pattes
il faudrait qu'ils aient un impact mais
ouais y'a papa de patrouille mais même
pas essayé le roi pourrait même rien du
tout voilà donc très jolie partie de
radia beaufort un peu moins peut-être
linéaire que la partie de la démission
précédente qu'on a vu râler a beau
dominer shirov sur une estonienne non
mais alors il ya un point commun dans
toutes les parties qui a gagné radjabov
c'est que dans les moments cruciaux vais
avoir le 30e coup où il donne toute son
énergie pour calculer ce qui va se
passer il est supérieur aux autres bien
supérieure pour l'instant alors
supérieur aux autres
il a joué pour l'instant contre les
derniers du tournoi c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas encore joué dans un bon mois
l'armée - bon ben je veux dire il a joué
contre les joueurs qui ferme la marche
bon le fait qu'ils aient battu et
contribue au fait qui ferme la marche
bien on en est là qu un point d avance
sur topalov donc ça va être de la partie
topalov radjabov votre capital mais je
pense que chronique radjabu va être pas
mal aussi parce que chroniqueuse va
vouloir le tester sur l'estonienne quand
même un kramnik quand même considéré
comme le joueur qui a
un peu démoralisés kasparov de jouer
l'estonienne c'est vrai faut savoir que
kaspar n'a plus joué l'estonienne
massacre a dit qu'il s'était fait
écraser je me rappelle en 1994 au
tournoi de moscou deux parties rapides
qui s'appelait le kremlin gp quoi grand
prix et c'était le premier tour les
quarts de finale où les huitièmes de
finale peut-être bien et et kasparov
s'étaient fait éliminer par cramique en
perdons une estonienne c'était une des
plus belles parties d'ailleurs de la
carrière de granit kramnik avait 10 g ni
kasparov pour ceux qui ont des banques
de données 1994
à moscou la meuse au kremlin en phase ii
avec vladimir poutine après il en a
gagné une autre contre kasparov une
citadine trame unique mais là pour
récemment ça veut dans les années 2000
et après quatre ans à convertir leur
match oui à voir le match parce qu'il
avait complètement arrêté et d'ailleurs
pendant le match n'a pas eu il ya pas eu
une estonienne et on s'attendait à en
voir au moins maintenant il a il a
arrêté kasparov s'est dissipée il a oui
kasparov avait eu des beaux succès dans
l'espagne est notamment contre karpov au
championnat du moins elle et puis aussi
dans un tournoi à las palmas où toutes
les pièces de karpov s'était retrouvé
sur la première rangée
oui superbe écrase des fantastiques
exactement donc on peut on peut dire que
ce qui ce qui quand même enthousiasme
ans dans ce tournoi chorus avec ce
radjabov cesser cette résurrection
l'estonienne voilà vraiment cessé ça
fait plaisir une joie de la résurrection
des risques avec les noirs parce que la
plupart des autres joueurs avec les
noirs ils ont pour elles c'est vrai je
joue plus pour les gars jouent là petrov
ouais le gambit d'aci topalov topalov
pour le karting dans l'escalier
topalov oui mais c'est vrai qu'en
chronique ou moi-même un norn son patron
pas agressif même pas du tout chronique
cherche pas gagné avec les noix un an de
dans ce genre de tournoi il fait
plusieurs parties nulles en moins de 25
ans oui mais il vise à contrecarrer
c'est un peu vu en a maintenant 30 meyer
il a eu un un point facile contre je
fidler qui a fait une grosse gaffe il va
gagner une telle réunion 23 ans 25 ou 26
ans de façon à nantes on le voit pour
les spectateurs et le conseil s'est pas
arriver en retard parce que ça c'est
vrai qu'il invite sa cellule rapide
phocéen massaquoi et c'est vrai ça va
tellement vite il joue très très vite il
est gardé et on le surnomme toujours
enfin le surnommer au début en tout cas
de sa carrière le lucky luke des échecs
l'homme qui joue plus vite que son ombre
vishy anand voilà donc l analyse de
cette partie navarra dialogue dans cette
émission des gones avec nicolas giffard
mais nous vous remercions de nous avoir
suivi on vous donne rendez vous et bien
pour les prochaines émissions hexagonal
merci à vous merci aux abonnés oubliez
pas diagonale tv.com vous pouvez vous
abonner à l'année pour recevoir toutes
les émissions nouvelles fait pour
diagonale tv actualité donc n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à déconnecter v
recevant les missions chez vous puis
soutenir l'émission par aussi par votre
abonnement
merci à tous et à bientôt sur des
modèles tv au revoir